was applied for accepting that there can
there are conditions under the operating
schedule
um
accepting all the conditions of the
operating schedule unless stated
hereafter
may have changed so
number one's been withdrawn
number two to add non-standard timings
for the sale of alcohol on and off
and opening hours to include boxing day
and any day preceding a bank holiday
between um
nine nine 000 900 hours and no 100 hours
note the non-standard time means to be
to be oh 900 hours to 100 hours alcohol
on and off
on and off the premises on christmas eve
boxing day new year's eve
instant pat's day in any day preceding a
bank holiday
item three to add recorded music on
boxing day
and any day preceding a bank holiday
between 0 900 hours and no 100 hours
note that non-standard timings to be
2300 hours to oh 100 hours
recorded music indoors and on christmas
eve
boxing day new year's eve saint pat's
day and any other day preceding a bank
holiday
right item four to vary the following
conditions in the operating schedule
condition 11 is withdrawn
and it's to be reinstated as per the
original license
page 38 of the report
condition 17 is withdrawn
and reinstate as per original license on
page 39 of the report
right condition
19 on page 39
use of the external drinking area will
not be permitted beyond 2300 hours
sunday to thursday
and midnight
on friday and saturday christmas eve
boxing day new year's eve and saint
pat's day and then the other day prior
to the bank holiday
the external area shall be used for
smoking only after the only after these
times so
we've raised the the terminal hour by
one hour on all on all the timings on
all the days all the days of the week
um
item five has been withdrawn
uh in light of the dppo and item six has
been withdrawn
and the existing layout to apply in
light of the dppo submission
and also
to revise the premises license to give
the correct address of
30 to 32 greenwood street
um
so
that's that's basically it i think we i
think we've acceded to to what you've
asked for so i don't
hoping you'll be happy with that don't
expect expect you with you will appeal
um however you will be notified formally
within five working days
um and we trust that we trust that it
seems to be a well-managed place
actually i think we've all we've all
agreed that uh with without the use of
doorstep
and it's well managed by
by the managers so we expect that
continue to continue and hopefully
we won't need we won't need to have a
review
on behalf of the neighbors for for
disruption so
so hope so continue to manage it well
and i'm sure it will be and and we wish
you every success with it
and thank you thank you chad thank you
for your time
thank you okay
thank you